[Música]
bienvenido a esta cultura france24 en
modo pandemia una versión que más que
frenar nos nos incita a plantearnos
cuanto más faltará para que todos
podamos vivir un concierto de lleno una
rave como las británicas de mediados de
los 90
[Aplausos]
[Música]
está claro que hasta que el cob y 19 no
esté bajo control global con vacunas
como norma esta pregunta no tendrá fecha
exacta o unánime pero con el optimismo
de dije me cal brothers hoy miramos los
indicios de esperanza para empezar éstos
son los países que o bien ya han vivido
un evento masivo como los de antaño o
bien los tienen previstos o los están
celebrando aunque con estudios china en
agosto de 2020 nos dejó la estampa de un
recital acuático sin mascarillas y este
abril ha sido la banda neozelandesa si
existe la que no está sorprendido
reuniendo 50.000 personas en el estadio
eden park
ciudadanos eufóricos de la célebre buján
no representan el panorama en
latinoamérica pero que así como las olas
del virus el festival strawberry sirve
de termómetro ya que después de 14 meses
un confinamiento reciente y 265 millones
de inoculaciones durante dos días 11.000
asistentes no estuvieron obligados a
cubrirse la única medida que se aplicó
fue restringir el aforo en sus tres
escenarios además de crear áreas
divididas en un éxito pensando en que
como todas las citas musicales el año
pasado fue virtual
[Música]
chivas es la meta a una normalidad pero
es europa la que está siendo laboratorio
real para la música con miles de jóvenes
dispuestos a ser cuerpo de pruebas todo
inició en agosto pasado cuando alemania
unió a 1400 espectadores en la arena
quarterback y mo williams para un triple
concierto controlado del cantante team
vents co
entonces fue extremo porque los
asistentes eran voluntarios de un
estudio universitario de acertado nombre
de revistar 19
cada uno tenía que cargar un rastreador
de localización más un desinfectante
fluorescente y se ubicaba según la
asignación de asientos en marzo países
bajos elevó la medición de brotes en
conciertos con 1500 personas francia
está en ello en toulouse y más allá
mientras que reino unido es el grupo ya
que el gobierno de boris johnson está
haciendo todo por anunciar festivales
este mayo además de los brit awards con
público blossoms viladoms y suso
actuaron frente a los primeros fans que
por seis horas se olvidaron del virus
una dosis de la vida sin pandemia sin
mascarillas ni distancias esta ha sido
la inyección para 5000 festivaleros
británicos preocupados solo en la música
y las bebidas en el marco de una prueba
del gobierno de liverpool se siente
fantástico estoy aquí con todos mis
amigos es bueno estar de regreso creo
que puede sentar un buen precedente para
los festivales de verano
para asistir a este show de 6 horas ya
todos tuvieron que presentar un test psr
negativo y se comprometieron a hacer
otro más pasado 5 días del evento esto
forma parte de la voluntad del gobierno
británico de buscar soluciones a grandes
reuniones sin riesgo a nuevos brotes los
científicos siguieron de cerca de
encuentro pusimos unas 40 cámaras
alrededor del sitio y observamos cómo se
mueven las personas y cómo se comportan
mientras asisten al festival como usan
sus mascarillas cómo se saludan antes
del mini festival el club nocturno
branly murdock warehouse realizó dos
eventos de prueba con 3.000 asistentes
la cita en la ciudad icónica de los
beatles contó con djs de tasa
internacional es surrealista una parte
de mí siente que no ha pasado el tiempo
y la otra que ha sido una eternidad las
conclusiones de estos actos son
observadas por los países vecinos
francia piensa celebrar festivales de
pruebas similares mientras que españa
ensaya un pase digital para ingresar a
clubes
[Música]
tras este recorrido es deber preguntarse
si en paralelo a las dosis estos ensayos
se sostienen y pueden ser protocolos
futuros el caso más analizado ha sido el
del concierto de love of lesbian en el
palau sant jordi de barcelona qué
medidas se tomaron uso de mascarillas
ffp2 test de antígenos el día del evento
rechazando cualquier positivo chequeos
de temperatura y tipo buján división del
recinto en tres sectores en total sólo
seis de 4.592 personas dieron positivo
en una nueva prueba pasados los 14 días
sin indicios de transmisión durante el
evento
si hoy arrojamos luz sobre el
espectáculo en vivo no es por necesidad
de aglomeraciones que también sino por
la reactivación del sector cuantos más
datos cuantas más quillas que demuestren
seguridad más actuará por la cultura que
en españa prevé hasta 25 festivales de
aquí a octubre y en eeuu se empezará a
activar en septiembre con él o hannah
festival dos grupos esperamos lograr dos
resultados
el primero es ver si podemos convencer a
las autoridades sanitarias para que
aumenten la capacidad de los espacios de
conciertos del 50% al 75% el otro
objetivo es encontrar la manera de
reanudar las fiestas y festivales de la
ciudad los espectáculos los festivales
no pudieron salir adelante en 2020 y
tienen que salir adelante este 2021
de lo contrario empresas profesionales y
artistas no sobrevivirán
según un estudio alemán que analizó el
movimiento de partículas si se garantiza
una renovación completa del aire en un
evento cerrado al menos una vez cada 20
minutos el riesgo será mínimo
si bien la mascarilla actúa como pared
el equipo valoró que conciertos el 50
por ciento de capacidad no son sitios de
infección ojalá políticas en este
sentido gracias por estar ahí y cuídense
mucho
[Música]
[Aplausos]